don't be fooled by the puppy-dog look
one certain trait of dogs is more
dangerous than others but usually
aggressive relative surprise behavior
and capable of massive damage the latest
in the string of attacks by the country
for breeding when they clamp down they
don't let go 370 cities and towns all
across this country single out pitbulls
and ban them and these bans empower
agents of the government to engage in a
rather remarkable intrusion into the
lives of otherwise law-abiding citizens
perfectly nice family friendly dogs who
are living as part of a family can be
seized and ultimately euthanized Allen
Grider a Vietnam War vet is talking
about precious you come in in the middle
of night when I've had PTSD and wake me
up and take me out of the Muto's in the
City of Aurora took precious from
grinder he's in my heart my soul that
dog was everything to me you're watching
your family member being taken on the
end of a choke chain they took her out
in the house for no reason the animating
idea behind these pitbull bands boils
down to this pitbulls are genetically
pre-programmed to be violent well that's
false
I'll let Janice Bradley one of the
country's foremost experts on dog
cognition drop the knowledge
this concept that aggression could be
traced back to specific breeds is the
folklore created by a criminal
subculture okay this is not a concept
that exists in science burgeoning
science with regard to cognition in dogs
illuminate how entwined dog behavior is
with human behavior they evolved to live
with human beings it's no longer really
scientifically viable or meaningful to
talk about domestic dogs except in
relationship to human beings that argues
against this idea that there's some
immutable quality that makes some
subculture of dogs dangerous any
objectionable behaviors that you see are
primarily environmental we know there
are certain things about aggressive dogs
that are true we know that they're under
socialized with humans are often
tethered or kept isolated from families
and they don't have social skills and in
Fairfax County we don't find any
correlation with breed on when it comes
to those characteristics so if dog
aggression is chiefly the function of
external factors not biology then
presumably pit bulls that have been
rescued from bad environments and
reintegrated into normal families would
become regular loving dogs well we
actually have exactly such a natural
experiment and it involves the most
famous pit bulls in the country April
2007 investigators uncovered an illegal
dogfighting operation on the Virginia
farm of NFL superstar quarterback
Michael Vick but the pit bulls rescued
from Michael Vick's farm were given a
second chance with incredible results
one of the dogs is a dog named Hector
lifts the dog's head for a little bit so
you can see would hold Hector PC major
on his chest and down his legs you see
the scars from from the fighting but
this dog is a therapy dog it's
unimaginable to me these scars are all
external he doesn't have any internal
scars and that's something 51 pits were
rescued from Michael Vick's farm fully
47 emerge from that sick sustained
torture session to get adopted and live
happy nonviolent lives no one would have
both predicted this never not in a
million years to get an even better
sense of how arbitrary the supposedly
innate character of pitbulls is consider
this breeds cultural position just a
century ago we have found a couple of
collections in the Library of Congress
showing dogs in DC around the like from
1890 to 1920 guess what they look like
these amazing pictures of like Downton
Abbey ladies with their bustles in their
corsets with their pit bull for them to
have gone from that place of honor in
our society you'd know that that's about
more than the dogs between 2000 and 2009
about 300 people were killed in dog
attacks every single one of those deaths
is a tragedy but they need to be put
into proper perspective even if every
single one of them was caused by a
pitbull those killer dogs would still
only represent a miniscule fraction of
the millions of pits in this country so
how about instead of just channeling
hype driven prejudices and empowering
police to pull dogs away from loving
families for no good reason
lawmakers reconstruct their regulations
and hold accountable the beam that's
actually responsible for that bloodshed
the human holding the leash